free speech wing of the free speech
party
this is how twitter executives love to
define their platform
the self-righteousness of this is only
matched by how far the twitter
executives
are detached from reality lately they
banned the nigerian president
over this tweet many of those
misbehaving today are too young to be
aware of the destruction and loss of
lives that occurred during the nigerian
civil war
those of us in the fields for 30 months
who went through the war
will treat them in the language they
understand twitter moderators
may not be able to find nigeria on the
map but apparently
their interpretation of the country's
history is more accurate than the
president's
who obviously wasn't impressed and his
government
wasn't taking any of that when people
were born in police stations and clean
policemen in nigeria
during answers for twitter
it was about the right to protest
but when a similar thing happened
on the capital it became insurrection
we are not going to be
fooled by anybody we have
a country to rule and would do so the
best of our ability
twitter wasn't ready for that and it is
hard to judge them for it
they had already successfully banned one
of the most
powerful men in the world and got away
with it consequence-free
nigeria though did something about it
the audacity we are deeply concerned by
the blocking of twitter in nigeria
access to the free and open internet is
an essential human right
in modern society just put everything
down for a second appreciate the
absolute illogical pandemonium here with
me
twitter which is very trigger-happy over
an arbitrary set of rules
to deny people the right to speak out
is trying to be the champion of free
speech you can't make this up
but the ban caught the eye of some
politicians who condemned it
the diplomatic missions of canada the
european union
the republic of ireland the united
kingdom and the united states of america
convey our disappointment over the
government of nigeria's announcement
suspending twitter
banning systems of expression is not the
answer
these measures inhibit access to
information and
commerce the information monster even if
it appears very attractive
can a dictate to a foreign state how to
live how to interpret historical events
what movies to watch or what music to
listen to
otherwise instead of freedom of speech
it becomes a dictatorship
of opinion for sole purpose and some
other politicians
who in turn got ideas twitter
non-compliance with our rules will lead
to unintended consequences
including twitter losing exemption from
liability as an intermediary
and perhaps more officials should take a
closer look at nigeria handling this
because if banning a president over an
opinion
somehow made it into twitter's
definition of free speech
we all need a lesson in how to deal with
big tech tyranny
twitter has no business deciding on what
geopolitical figures have to say about
anything because they're not
they're not informed enough to do so
they're just uh are responding
based on their own political prejudices
uh with very little knowledge about what
the situation
involves especially in nigeria twitter
uh is pretending to be the government of
the world
along with other social media platforms
they are trying to institute their own
sort of
governmental power these social media
platforms combined have more power than
all the nations of of the world in
effect all the states in the world
uh in terms of political influence so no
this is not surprising and it's not
unwarranted that these nations would be
trying to curb
twitter's political power